there were two headlines coming out of
yesterday's
appeal result in the miles garrett case
if you're watching on tv that's what
sparked the indefinite suspension there
was an appeal on tuesday ruling came on
wednesday or actually wednesday and the
ruling came on thursday that
miles garrett will be indefinitely
suspended at a minimum for the remainder
of the season with his status evaluated
after the season and something i wrote
last night and we need to emphasize this
it was important for the nfl to have the
ability to revisit miles garrett's
status after the season because the nfl
needs to be sure that what happened last
thursday night will never happen again
not just by anyone but specifically by
miles garrett you can't put him back on
the football field with other guys who
ultimately could suffer the same outcome
unless you're sure that it won't happen
again whether that requires anger
management some form of counseling
whatever it takes the nfl needs to
devise a system for ensuring that this
will not happen again because if it does
happen again
you've got some
moral responsibility to whoever would
get hit over the head and possibly
seriously injured and you're gonna have
some legal responsibility so there's
every reason for the nfl to have that
opportunity after the season to decide
when if and under what circumstances
miles garrett comes back so it was the
right outcome it was a stern punishment
with an open-ended future that allows
the nfl to be 100 sure because you can't
you can't take a risk here you have
somebody who has shown a propensity to
cross a line that had never before been
crossed during an nfl game
you have to be sure that when you put
that guy back out on the field he won't
react under similar circumstances
the same way now
why did he do what he did that's
something that miles garrett apparently
did not want to have ultimately come out
i'm not sure why because it was reported
yesterday that mason rudolph uttered a
racial slur and that is what sparked the
confrontation now
it's not clear that mason rudolph did
it's what miles garrett has claimed the
nfl says it's found no evidence of it
well no objective proof of it i mean
there is evidence of it miles garrett
says it happened and mason rudolph
vehemently denies it
through people other than mason rudolph
rudolph's attorney says
it's a shameful accusation the team
through bert lawton the spokesman
said that mason vehemently denies the
report of being accused of using a
racial slur during the incident thursday
night in cleveland he will not discuss
this accusation any further
see i have two concerns with this and i
don't know what happened
but from rudolph's perspective
if you're
that
certain that you didn't do this you
can't take the position you're not going
to discuss it he hasn't discussed it at
all
let him be grilled let him be questioned
the same way any player is questioned
about anything that happens on the field
the idea that you're not going to talk
about it
the next time he's available to the
media do you think they're not going to
ask him about it i'd like to think they
will
i want to hear him deny it and if he's
innocent i want to hear the indignation
in his voice how dare he accuse me of
doing something like that not only does
he hit me over the head with my own
helmet he accuses me of saying something
i never said
now my other concern
miles garrett
the night of the incident you're at your
locker
there's been no opportunity to be
managed
wrangled
to have your words finagled
or massaged look if you were mad enough
in the moment to remove mason rudolph's
helmet and hit him over the head with it
i'd like to think you're still mad
enough 15 minutes later
to say
that guy used a racial slur
i overreacted
but he used a racial slur so i don't
know what to believe here i've got
concerns on both sides i'm skeptical
because we didn't hear anything about
this until thursday a week later
and i'm skeptical because mason rudolph
won't face the music and talk about it
if you didn't do it why won't you talk
about it
garrett issued a statement
after the news came out of his claim
that a racial slur was uttered
this was not meant for public
dissemination
nor was it a convenient attempt to
justify my actions or restore my image
in the eyes of those i disappointed i
know what i heard
whether my opponent's comment was born
out of frustration or ignorance i cannot
say but his actions do not excuse my
lack of restraint in the moment and i
truly regret the impact this had on the
league the browns and our devoted fans
and look here's the thing
if it was said it's inexcusable but the
reaction
was even more inexcusable
plenty of ugly nasty things get said all
the time on a football field some of
them aren't grossly inappropriate some
of them are i'm not excusing it
but
we have seen nfl games played and we've
heard stories of horrible things said
and horrible things done at the bottom
of the pile for years
nothing has ever provoked someone to
remove an opponent's helmet and hit him
over the head with it so
i it clearly was an overreaction
and as i said earlier i i wish this
would have come why there's nothing
miles garrett did nothing wrong
as it relates to what was said to him
yes he clearly did something wrong
afterward but if there was some sort of
provocation
you got you got to share that you got to
let that be known so we can properly
assess the situation again doesn't make
what he did right but at least we'd have
a better understanding as to why he blew
a gasket the way he did we're going to
talk more about this with tony grocery
of espn cleveland later in the hour i
want to get some of the local reactions
i'll tell you what there's some folks in
cleveland who who are defending miles
garrett far more aggressively than i
thought they would
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports